Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
it's checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
So you know your week's going,
hi.
You're holding up how you're handling today's top stories in the news.
Um,
I haven't seen much about it,
but I guess Nike,
uh,
got on board with the colon.
Karnok Colin Kaepernick,
right?
Say Hey,
sometimes you gotta do what it is to get debt.
Right.
And then everybody,
you know,
you know the deal,
you know people are,
it's like,
Hey,
my point is about police brutality and ever since nine 11 a bit.
Yes sir.
Sir.
We're not talking about that.
No one is saying that your brother is not over in Iraq.
He's talking about police brutality.
What?
And that right.
There is political discourse
in 2018.
Yeah.
You know,
not saying people listen back in the day,
but at least they,
they,
they did a better job pretending,
you know,
well,
what,
where does Nike get off acting like they give a fuck about people.
You know,
if they really gave a shit,
people wouldn't they have allowed that documentary exposing their fucking
sweatshops to air at some point.
Oh,
shots fired and bill,
if,
uh,
if you gave a shit,
wouldn't you not be wearing a Nike shirt right now?
Hey,
fair enough.
We're all full of shit.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
If I see one more fucking moron,
okay.
Yeah,
no screaming about troops or nine 11 on a subject that has nothing to do with
it.
Okay?
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's a protest about police brutality.
He is allowed to do this law.
I'm allowed to misconstrue good Straw.
What he's saying,
Dad.
Dad,
okay.
You know,
but that's what it is.
I think that's what happened with the Internet is now everything.
Even when it isn't about you,
it has to be about you.
Okay.
You know all of these fucking people,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it just,
it just be all of this shit.
Oh,
this fucking shit you see on Instagram with a person's acting like they're
trying to inspire you when they're really just trying to show you all the cars
they have outside of their fucking a giant house with their abs.
You know the fuck was I joking about that with,
I did the Bill Simmons podcast that was joking about that.
You know,
all these fucking celebrities always telling you how hard they're working.
Yo,
we out here grinding.
It's like everybody.
Everybody is.
A lot of people weren't blessed.
Most people were not blessed with your gifts.
They're grinding does not fill an arena,
you know,
but there are really good fucking carpenter,
but no one's going to sit there and watch him frame of fuck.
Well,
I guess you wouldn't frame a house as a carpenter,
a finished carpet.
Nubson I'm thinking,
what are you saying,
Bill,
that regular carpenters aren't as good as finished carpenters?
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
you can hide a lot of your mistakes in the walls.
Hey,
Mike.
Um,
he built a shack and I rack,
that's not what I was talking about.
Obs.
I struck it felt like yelling.
MMM.
Anyways,
I saw a little bit of it.
I saw somebody retweets something and it was something about Fox News,
of course,
trash and Kaepernick of course saying he's not American.
Uh,
and of course saying probably that,
you know,
he doesn't support the troops because he's talking about police brutality.
Oh,
the weather outside is frightful.
Um,
so there you go.
But by all means,
you know,
people,
uh,
you know,
don't burn your own property,
even if he don't like Nike,
she could give it to a homeless guy.
And also when you burn that stuff,
you just really polluting your own environment.
Yeah.
With all that rubber and God knows what else is on the fucking sneaker,
what do you have to burn it?
Why can't you just throw them out or set them aside?
Yeah,
I,
he's got to burn it.
I remember when Lane Kiffin lift left fucking Tennessee in this guy somehow at
some lane Kiffin Jersey and he liked,
lit it on fire,
filmed it and then pissed on it.
Okay.
You Renell we went off lake link,
you and leave and Tanner see per buck and UFC.
Uh,
what do you think about it?
An American corporation poisoning our own food supply.
What
are you going to let your cornflakes on fire and then pee on him
or do you and I says,
what the fuck you talking about?
You Bald headed freckled mother fucking Yankee Code word the fuck you do now.
No southern guy ever said can't do.
They can't if birken curd,
that's how they see it.
Um,
our brain,
why am I acting like it's everybody down the south burning their Nike's?
No,
no,
no.
I don't know why there's not more people saying like this was about police
brutality.
You may or may not agree with it.
Well,
to then try and make it about something else,
which then leads you to burn your own sneakers.
It's probably not the direction you want to go in.
However,
that's not what you know.
But the thing is is if somebody is burning their own sneakers and then you show
it on TV,
like all of those channels you flipping through,
right?
There's this,
the fucking the lawyer chick,
right?
You flipped the channel.
There's the,
there's the Jack Ryan Guy.
You flip the channel is decipher.
You flip the channel.
There's a commercially of flip.
The channel is a saga gave you flip the channel.
Somebody sneakers are on fire,
you're going,
what the fuck is that
okay
with somebody in those,
when those caught on fire?
My God,
what?
What,
how did those sneakers catch on fire if fire?
Well,
yeah,
you know what?
I think we cracked the code here.
People for anyone in Hollywood listening to this,
if you want to hit series,
you need fire.
That'll make people stop.
But it's got to look real.
So in other words,
yeah.
You know like when you shoot without a permit,
you got to like light something on fire without permission and then it'll look
real because it is real.
And if you can somehow capture the people running out of whatever the fuck you
lit on fire,
then I think you could actually get people to stop long enough and possibly sit
through some commercials that they would allow your show to air for the
following week.
So see,
I guess there is a silver lining
for the life of me.
I will never fucking understand people that take it to that fucking level.
I get Nikkei,
he not agree.
Well,
let's say you know it's about police brutality,
but you're like,
that's not the way to go about protesting.
Fine.
I get that.
Fair enough.
Good point to you sir or madam,
but wouldn't like you take it to the point that like,
you know,
you're going to burn your shit
and then film it and then upload it onto the Internet and no point during any of
that fucking process.
You like those sneakers when it was just crying children's sewn them together,
didn't ya?
You don't like how fucked up.
I mean,
how far back will be going to take this?
You know,
if you really care,
all right,
then you wouldn't buy those things in the first place.
You'd be going down to the fucking,
uh,
sneaker factory and given that little kid a break and you'd sit down on the
stool and you'd fucking glue your shit together yourself,
wouldn't you,
wouldn't you?
Um,
okay.
I Dunno.
All I know is I'm sitting here right now and I don't have the Internet.
I'm a 50 year old man.
I don't have the Internet.
I don't know when I'm going to be able to upload this.
Uh,
I once again upgraded my sister,
you know,
my,
a buddy of mine was just telling me,
Greg Fitzsimmons just at his podcast.
I don't know when that's going to air,
but gee,
Bill,
why are you doing all these podcasts?
Well,
cause I got some big tour dates coming up in f is for family season three is
right around the corner.
The the fuckers done,
man.
We're getting ready to start promoting.
MMM.
Well you better from when my brother over don't burn my sneakers.
I will burn my fucking sneakers.
Hey Nike out.
You're Welch's.
Yeah.
Oh,
burning my fucking sneakers.
Don't make me burn my pullover cause I'll fucking do it.
Just do it.
Yeah,
I'll fucking do it.
I'll come over there like your whole fucking factory on fire.
How dare you kneel during the national anthem.
Yeah.
My knee.
I did how disrespectful kneeling is.
Yeah.
Whenever I go to church and
to send everybody to take their news.
It's like I will not disrespect guide but get no,
I'm a fucking nice.
Everybody knows if you believe in Jesus,
you stand up,
you go eyeball to eyeball with that hip is some bitch and you see how you
measure up.
You look at him in the eye,
okay,
maybe you're a little taller looking down on him being like,
Hey Jay,
fuck was up with that hooker man.
Okay.
Or maybe you're you.
You want them little fellows boot with a big heart.
Just keep come knock 'em down.
Keep coming.
Okay.
Like a fuck a wolverine.
Fucking Michigan Wolverines is sponsored by Nike.
I'm going to go in there and I'm going to burn all them tight little yellow
pants.
They run around it.
Is it a hug?
Their buttocks is in such a way.
I'm sorry people.
I don't have the Internet right now so I can't look up anything about sports,
so you're just going to have to suffer through another fucking 20 minutes of
this.
Okay.
I'm contractually obligated to continue running my fucking mouth for another 19
minutes.
The contract.
I signed with myself kind of Likewhen,
Motley Crue signed that contract that they were never going to tour again
because if they did then I guess they're going to sue themselves.
That's how that works.
Okay.
I'm sitting here right now.
I am staring at a VCR DVD player.
Okay.
And uh,
I'm trying to find,
you know,
I don't have the Internet.
I'm trying to find a fucking radio shack or something.
Oh Jesus.
What did I just do?
I can't hear myself.
There we go.
Now I can hear myself.
You know,
I just literally just fucking bought this shit and now it doesn't work.
You know what?
I'm going to blame.
I'm gonna Blame Colin Kaepernick.
Yeah.
Uh,
anyways,
the fuck of somebody texted me here.
Well,
I'm meandering through this Goddamn podcast.
Um,
okay.
But there's best buy still sell the shit you need for that.
Does anybody know
that's one of those things,
man,
when you hang onto the old technology,
cause I got all my old standup tapes over here on VHS.
I converted most of them.
And then there's other ones and it's just like,
I dunno what the fuck is only shit before I go send it over there.
Well
trying to think,
did I ever make a porno?
You got to ask yourself before you send your VHS tick you get here VCR man,
it's this new fangled fucking machine.
Yeah.
Is it put up on Nacky cause I'll light it on fire.
MMM.
Some redneck is going to go to a Chinese restaurant and accidentally light one
of the people there on fire.
You know,
cause he's going to give them a tip and he's going to be like,
do you like you know you like and she's going to be I like e and then he's going
to think she said Nike and then that.
See that.
See that how that happens.
It's a slippery slope.
Once you start,
you start lighting shit on fire man.
Like you don't know where,
where's it going to stop?
I mean maybe if you do it,
you start to like it,
right?
And then the next time your wife's like,
hi,
could you take the trash out?
And you're walking over their shoulders slump looking down at the linoleum
defeated man.
You get like a foot away from the trash.
It's suddenly just remember
how good it felt to let your own sneakers on fire.
Oh,
of a sudden you lift that fucking head up proud for the first time in years.
Okay.
And you knew that.
You know what?
You want me to take this trash out?
You fucking bitch.
I'll take it out.
I'm allotted on fire and I'm a film it and I'm going to put it on the Internet
and then we'll see what them sneakers sale and motherfuckers say then
mmm.
16 minutes to go.
Oh geesh.
Um,
the red sox are playing 500 bull.
When is Chris sale coming back?
I have no,
he's the guy.
He is the guy that prevents us
from slicer.
Fucking funny.
Everybody I told,
you know I told those fuckers at ESPN,
they wouldn't listen to me.
They don't.
They are afraid to listen to this podcast when they said the fuck and Yankees
got swept.
This division series is over.
Yeah,
he said that the first week of fucking August.
And what did bill say?
What did the balding freckled con who never played baseball belong beyond the
minor or major leagues.
Okay.
Got kicked out of baseball because he got a d in math in 19 fucking 79 was the
last time I played in an organized league and even I could see it even I was
going,
hey,
wait a minute.
ESPN.
Okay.
There's like 60 fucking games left and were up by nine and a half games.
I don't know what kind of fucking Muslim asses textbook you're looking at.
The numbers don't add up.
Um,
yeah,
we'll probably going to win like 105 games.
I even know where the fuck we're at right now.
Last I saw he was like 91 or 92 probably go 500 for the rest of the fucking
year.
You know,
it's an,
it's never fucking Yogi Berra said,
it's not over till it's over.
He said that before there was a wild card,
a one game playoff,
19 fucking rounds of baseball.
He said that back when all you had to do was win the fucking division and you
won the pennant and then you had to win four more games.
You won the world series.
Even that fucking guy
who essentially mocked mentally challenged people his entire life with is
planned out.
Goofy Sakes,
right?
Plain Glib.
The whole time,
like a hot chick trying to get some free drinks.
Never figured out what that guy's angle was.
Even he said,
it ain't over till it's over.
Who said what first
bye.
Sounded like Abbott and Costello who said it ain't over till it's over first or
like what came first that or it ain't over until the fat lady sings,
right.
Everybody knows if you want to hear somebody could sink,
you gotta get a fat woman,
right?
Fat Woman,
fat woman listen to was saying and mine is not that theme song and they come
walking out,
oh,
he's had some sort of flair on for a code or some sodas,
some sort of,
I dunno what something but dazzled coming out day with their fat feet.
Fucking
just all squeezed into those little pumps.
[inaudible] who right singing the shit out of the national anthem.
Why would they send at the end of the game?
You know why?
I bet.
Because they didn't have fucking jumbo trons back in the day.
You don't see,
everybody's just walking out and all you could hear was the sound of fucking
people stepping on empty peanut shells.
Okay.
Just racist shit.
Right.
They had to stop people from being racist to each other to get them out of it.
And that's just the white people.
You're fucking day go bastard.
I mean a fucking Irish bastard.
Fuck you're,
you're fucking Daigo right back then when like the Irish and the Italians,
like white people were like racist against each other.
Yeah.
Polish people,
all of that shit.
They needed to keep him calm when they walked out of the ballpark.
So then they just have some fat lady come waddling out there.
Everybody could laugh at her.
God,
well,
you know what?
I might have fucking tuberculosis.
At least my feet aren't oozing out of my shoes.
And she'd get out there singing and [inaudible] five [inaudible] bars.
Jaymar Mike.
Okay,
everybody just put on the fucking derbies and they walked up.
take me out to the ball game.
Take me back to my neighborhood where everybody looks like me and we fucking
cabbage for three cause where I rich people in the Irish section of they'll
fucking town.
Keep your pasty freckled fucking ass in your own neighborhood.
Right.
So weird how they glorify that,
that error in sports.
A simpler time.
The good old days of baseball.
They way they tell it two different ways that you,
they either have like that,
that version we're Billy crystal talks about going to the Yankees game and
seeing Mickey Mantle or they do the real shit,
the Jackie Robinson story that it's just like,
oh,
okay.
And all in.
It's the exact same fucking footage other than that black cat being thrown on
the field.
Other than that,
it's all the exact same footage and how you're viewing it has less to do with
what they're saying and more to do with the music that they play underneath it.
11 minutes to go.
I don't have my rear right now.
I'd be reading my fucking advertising and I could get through this part,
but I don't fucking have it
by the way.
Butcher box.
You're welcome.
Okay.
I have blown up heritage bread.
Pork.
Okay.
I blown it up.
I brought,
I brought it back.
It was so fucking far gone.
People didn't even know it was missing.
I had never heard,
I've been eating pork chops my entire fucking life.
Okay.
Bacon,
Ham and cheese sandwiches got older.
I moved to New York.
I was introduced to a Cuban sandwich.
Right.
All of that fucking
what do they got their welcome whenever I think I got to go fucking
cause you're dumb bill.
Oh that's probably it.
Pork Butt,
right?
Pork shoulder.
Is it really the ass of the pig and they just say pork shoulder cause they don't
want you to be reminded,
you know,
they do say rump roast,
right?
Yeah.
Hey,
all you guys out there burning your sneakers,
you know,
you also have like an apocalypse like game plan,
you know what I mean?
You like Bill Walsh,
she call in all the plays in the first half and I'm just fucking showing up and
I'm not even going to know what the fuck's going to hit me.
Right.
I have an apocalypse plant to die within the first hour.
Oh Shit.
That's that.
I mean that is the ultimate plant,
you know,
cause then I,
then I get to be a ghost.
Right.
And I'm already as white as one.
That might be my,
my disguise.
The freckles would give me away.
MMM.
No,
you die within the first hour and then you just hang around you.
What you don't like.
Remember Patrick Swayze and uh,
Moondance,
whatever the fuck fucking movie was called,
our hair to Tahoe.
Okay.
A dad or not damaged with this chick and her knows that she chose to change.
You know,
Wade,
that was weird.
Um,
ghost.
Jesus Christ.
I said I wanted to be a fucking ghost.
Okay?
Yeah,
I remember that.
When he would look up at the light,
evidently you have an option when you die.
All right?
If you go into hell,
you don't have an option.
You just get manhandled.
Look like you grabbed some chicks ass at the club.
These fucking Damon's just come up or they just grab you and then that's it.
But if you lived a good life,
if he took out their trash and you didn't light it on fire,
I guess you could look up at the light and,
and God gives you the option.
You're like,
hey man,
you want to come behind the velvet rope boy?
Like,
do you just want to fucking,
you want to be a voyeur for awhile?
I'm not judging,
dude.
This isn't going to go against your record.
Okay?
You done good.
You did good enough to get up here.
You know there's another train coming in and a couple of weeks if you want to
just fucking hang around.
I mean you got to hang around,
right?
You got to go Tom Sawyer and hang out at your own funeral.
That'd be,
that'd be no funerals at the fucking apocalypse.
There'll be the old school ones.
Yeah.
They fucking dig up fucking foot and a half foot trench.
Deep Trench.
He does hope.
They don't see anything sparkling in the dirt or they're just going to leave you
out in the open and keep digging
is that you?
Rainium
you know it's going to have an easy time during the apocalypse are going to be
the hipsters cause they're already like,
they already have the fucking grizzly Adams beard.
So this stay warm in the winter.
They're already,
you know,
they know how to make like their own jam and fucking beer in the bathtub.
Like all this old school stuff.
Some of them know how to make their own clothes.
Like I think hipsters are going to be,
I think they're going to be all right.
And we're all going to be like,
wow.
You know what?
I remember I wanted to fight that kid cause he told me that he's learning how to
be a blacksmith,
you know,
and the other kid was building a steam ship and then all of a sudden the
apocalypse is going to happen.
You'll be like,
you know something.
Those are some skills I wish I had right now.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh,
this is like the longest fucking podcast ever.
Okay.
Five minutes to go.
Jesus Christ.
Five minutes left.
Okay.
Um,
I'm going to be in Sacramento this weekend.
Everybody know north of Sacramento.
I'm doing a casino up there with a rose bowl tailgate.
Lez Legend Jason Law,
head master,
flat top grill.
Shep,
master smoker.
Math.
You put them on a green egg.
A fucking,
a standard fucking grill.
Demand is going to eat.
He's going to make something.
He just makes,
he makes everyone around him better.
Okay.
With like,
you know,
it'd be like if you just add that player that causes everybody to elevate their
game.
The second we added Jason Law had to the fucking tailgate.
Everybody had a few more beers,
right?
Everybody?
Uh,
I dunno,
eight,
a little bit more every,
but everybody just took it a little bit more and we got this extra for the first
time ever,
we made it to the playoffs of arguably the top,
whatever,
400 tailgates in our section.
Now there's some people that throw down,
man,
they bring like satellite dishes and shit and like TVs,
you know.
But I'm telling you,
you wanna you want to bring the fucking flat top fucking grill.
Okay.
All right.
What's the God damn propane tank?
None of that shit squat and around with your little firebox trying to get the
coals burning and all of that shit.
Fuck that.
Yeah,
you just turn on the gas.
We weekly quick.
Let that fucking thing.
Heat up.
Drink a bloody Mary and next thing you know fucking,
you mean you making yourself an egg sandwich with bacon.
Ah,
delicious.
Toasting up your ag mic.
Yeah,
you're fucking,
yeah.
Yo English muffins.
That's just breakfast.
Now you've moved on to Whiskey,
right?
It's fucking pro.
I got the flat top going over a
over Labor Day.
And by the way,
I'm telling you,
I made the,
I made the practice Burger,
I took it right out of the fridge and I was like,
you know,
I should have fucking had this spin room temperature but I don't have the time.
And I threw it on.
I did five minutes,
both sides.
I made sure it was nice and thin or whatever.
Um,
it was,
I guess a little too thick and I took it off,
had a nice crunch to it and everything.
But when we got to the middle,
it was like rare.
So I was like,
well thank fucking God.
I didn't,
by the way,
I hate,
it's still,
I still ate it.
Fucking hamburger in the middle of it was like the consistency of bubblegum and
a very dangerous,
very dangerous thing to do.
You can,
you can get away with that with steak because you just fucking with one steer at
that point.
But hamburger is just like a million stairs,
you know what I mean?
That's like,
you know,
eat that raw.
That's like going raw with a porn star.
You have no idea how many people you just fucked.
So I took the meat out of the fridge,
got it at room temperature,
and then I did six minutes on both sides and uh,
got nothing but compliments.
So there,
there's a little tip for you and this little tip that I learned from a pro chef
is you got to get up to you.
Got,
you got to hit a fucking breakfast ball.
All right?
You got to make one for yourself.
You make the mistake on your own.
All right.
If I just took all that meat out and just throw it on there,
everybody would have had bubble gum in the middle of fucking raw meat in the
middle of their burgers.
They'd have to take the fucking buns off and all of that messy shit and I'd have
to put it back on and everybody would be looking at me like my balls just rolled
off the fucking porch.
What kind of a man does it?
Not a cook over an open flame,
Huh?
That's what they would be saying.
But nope.
Didn't say that about me
because in private when no one was around,
I failed miserably.
Okay.
And that's one to growing for the love of God.
Is that 30 minutes,
29 minutes.
One minute to go.
People.
What have we learned here?
We've learned that bill can do a southern accent.
We've learned that anytime anybody's dumb bill does a southern accent,
we've learned that bill has watched dirty dancing and ghost.
And uh,
I think I did an advertisement for eating pigs and putting them on a flat top
grill.
I don't know what else you fucking need out of this.
At some point this will be uploaded.
And the next thing you're going to listen to his,
uh,
audio of me on my cell phone,
probably reading
that should have already been read at this point.
When I wrapped it up on Saturday,
this Saturday I'll be at the Toronto Film Festival for the Premiere of the front
runner star and Hugh Jackman who's already getting Oscar buzz.
Uh,
it's going to be very exciting to be a,
to be that close man,
to be that close to the biggest trophy out here in Hollywood.
And I ain't talking about your third wife.
There's a southern accent again.
Um,
yeah,
it's going to be,
it's going to be cool.
I am so fucking site and feel so lucky that I got to be in that movie.
Everybody knows seeing the trailer,
except everybody who listens to this,
who will now write negative shit,
hip,
all have positive things to say about it.
And I'm like I said,
don't blink.
If you blink,
you're gonna miss me,
but you will not and I guarantee you will not miss my mustache.
All right,
that's it.
Have a great weekend.
You cunts.
Enjoy the reads.
A little bit of music and then I'm going to give you another 30 minutes for free
of a greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a month,
uh,
for our Thursday earlier this year,
years ago.
I have no idea.
I forget how the system works.
Don't talk to me about it.
All right,
that's it.
I'll see y'all later.
All right,
time for the advertising.
Speak of the devil.
It's butcher box.
Butcher your box delivers healthy.
100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage bread,
pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets,
starts with the commitment to raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they're slaughtered.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual sized meals.
Unless you're a fat bastard or a competitive eater,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts there for $20 off your first box in two
pounds of free ground,
brief and every box for the rest of your life,
uh,
for the rest of the life of your subscriptions.
Here's me,
that's $20 off your first box and two pounds of fresh meat a month.
And for people who are already butcher box subscribers,
you'll have a special deal on ground brief and you can take advantage of by
logging into your account.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
All right,
who's next?
Oh,
it's hymns.
H,
I m s is a problem.
66% of their men lose their hair by age 35 Jesus,
I got past 35 without that then it was all downhill.
Thing is when you start to notice hair loss.
It's too late.
It's easy to keep the hair you have them to replace the hair you've lost.
Is that a hairline slew really starting to move backward?
Any bald spots yet?
How will you feel a year from now if it's business as usual up there?
Why did guys turned a weird solutions or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science?
I feel like they're insulting me here.
What [inaudible] does is correct you correct connect you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair loss well known generic equivalents,
to name brand prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counters.
Supplements,
prescription solution backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to for hymns.com answer a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and creams can prescribe you.
A products are shipped directly to your door order.
Now my listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 right now while supplies
last.
See the website for full details.
This would,
this would cost you hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr that's f o r a h I m s.com/burr for
hims.com/burr.
Don't end up looking like me.
All right,
drag.
What'd you,
if they took me under their wing and they got me all my fucking hair back,
how weird would that be?
A do it before.
It'd be weird.
All right.
Draft kings,
everybody.
A football returns 10 night yet that that Dab,
boop,
boop and huge cash prizes are up for grabs and draft kings,
the leader in one week.
Fantasy sports for the season opener.
Draft kings is hosting a fantasy football context contest.
That's just $10 to enter and it has a $1 million top prize.
But for a limited time,
if you sign up with the code bird,
but you are,
our draft kings will give you a free entry with your first deposit single game
show down as the newest way to play.
Just drafts.
Six players from Thursdays game.
Stay under the salary cap and see how your team stacks up against the
competition,
puts your football knowledge to work and you could win 1 million bucks while
watching the season opener.
You don't have to come in first to be a winner.
There are two and a half million dollars in total prices,
which means thousands and thousands of winners.
Download the APP or go to draftkings.com now and use code bur bur are to sign up
and make your first deposit.
When you do drive,
kings will give you a shot at 1 million bucks this Thursday.
That's code bur bur are at only a draft.
Kings and minimum is a $5 deposit.
Eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
All right.
Um,
before we hit play the audio from back in the day,
there's a little bit of audio here from uh,
I called in a sports gambling podcast and I gave my picks for tonight's game and
a few others over the weekend.
And then we got some throwback clips.
Enjoy the music.
Thank you guys for listening and have a wonderful weekend.
Your sons of bitches,
Bill Burr on the sports gaming podcast is brought to you by my book.
He died eg.
My book,
he is the leader in online sports books.
Use the Promo Code Bill Bets for 800% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid at my bookie.
Dot.
Agee joining us on the line,
Bill Burr.
Bill,
how excited are you that football is officially back?
Oh,
this is the greatest time of year.
It's Jagan.
An La is starting to get colder at night.
I love it.
I'm actually,
I,
you know,
I know there's all these new rules and they could barely hit each other.
Oh my God,
I don't care.
I don't even care if it's flag football.
It's football.
I'm sorry.
Is this the best football into Halloween and the Thanksgiving and Christmas.
I love it.
My favorite time of year,
honestly,
Sean,
it's the feeling I get when I uh,
when I give myself a little,
uh,
abstinence from the old medication and then I get to indulge again and,
and that,
that first like sinking into the couch.
That's football for me.
I'm,
I'm stoked.
It's back.
Yeah.
Comfort food baby.
It is so great.
I feel like they scared us a little bit in the a week two and week three of the
pre season.
They were just flagging everything.
Any,
any uh,
guy lowers his helmet even though he's got his head up trying to hit him right
in the chest.
They're throwing a flag and then all of a sudden week for the preseason,
all those flags dried up.
I have a feeling when it comes.
Yeah.
Thursday night we'll see.
Very few of those penalties actually called the,
because the refs are just as big a fan of football as us and they know it'll
just kill the game if they do it all the time.
I think they set up,
don't,
the reps aren't making that call.
It's the top talent to do it.
This is the deal.
At some point,
if the game's going to get tenure,
you're just going to have to sign a release.
So if you want to play this at a professional level,
these are the risks and they're going to make you like,
they're probably drawing up that contract right now.
You can never come back and sue us.
I mean,
look,
if if,
if the state or the federal government can put you in jail for like 30 years and
then realized they screwed up and the only way they let you out as you can't sue
them.
I'm sure the NFL can draft something.
Yeah.
See these for these people,
that belt,
they'll come up with something.
So I think the game will be okay.
Yeah.
The same people who drew up the warnings for cigarettes now,
the Philip Morris guys,
they'll meet up with the NFL.
They'll figure it out.
Hey,
you just got to put this warning on the helmet.
You know,
we'll still be good.
Yeah,
come on.
It was great.
It did feel like this,
uh,
this college football weekend leading into the NFL was almost a kind of a warmup
or play baby.
Yeah.
Did you watch football?
Because football has been like,
it's just been what it's been all about man for the last few years.
Like it's just,
it's so exciting.
And then they finally figured out not to have all those like just a hundred
cupcake games.
You know,
like I remember back in the day when you would gamble in like in like,
uh,
September,
like Nebraska would be favored by 58 over at Kent State and then they'd cover,
it was like ridiculous.
Um,
but now there was smart enough where they had,
they had the Michigan Notre Dame game.
They had Lsu Miami,
they're the Florida state game last night.
I missed all of that.
I was doing some daddies labor day stuff with the family.
I missed that one.
But,
um,
I I absolutely,
I love college football as much as I love pro so much to my wife's Chagrin my
entire weekend and this weekend I'm actually in Sacramento and then I got to go
to the Toronto Film Festival.
Uh,
so I'm missing Saturday football and I'm flying home during the one o'clock
game.
So this is going to be a lot of Dvr and going on in my house.
Oh that's my favorite thing.
Every season is the really football's back already.
It's only August wasn't it?
Just the draft.
What happens then you've got the combine and then you just go,
hey honey,
one of the real housewives in the off season.
Exactly.
The Bachelor is a full time sport.
Like you know the NFL should be as well.
Yeah that ain't that Andy Cohen show.
That's their sports center where they get those women all stirred up again.
What about on this plate,
which she said you're,
you're barren and you couldn't have children.
They start yelling at each other.
It's like watching her round the horn.
Yeah,
it does.
It does it in the pacing of a studio show cause they bring up game film.
They're breaking it down.
What do you,
you know,
they have former players,
former bachelor's weighing in turning point.
Madden a telestrator over there.
That's great.
That's the only way I could,
I had to like get like look at my wife's perspective and just be like,
this is just her sports center.
And then I was able to kind of relax and then I really look at a lot of the,
you know,
it's a lot of the sports chatter out there.
It's just so ridiculous.
It's like somebody like me who's not even connected to it.
Just be,
I'll tell you,
I'm really concerned about a middle relief,
you know,
talking baseball.
It's like,
oh are you somebody who never played beyond not getting picked in gym class.
The we thing is always funny.
Sean's a big fan of doing that with the egg.
But I do enjoy the,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're going to win it all this year.
It is a way,
it's a way because if you don't win,
you get all this crap.
You guys saw that show you aren't modeled,
Blah.
Then all of a sudden your win and then the other guys like
we're easy there,
but you didn't play.
But what do you mean?
Yeah,
when,
when I wake up Monday and the eagles got their ass kicked,
I'm fucking depressed.
All right.
I have to live with that.
These guys,
that's just a job for them.
This is my fucking life.
So yeah,
I may dress right
and people give you shit saying you guys suck.
You guys show Philly's a bunch of losers and then all of a sudden if you're win
every that that's when you know you want to gain.
When people say,
oh,
we,
it's not we,
it's like,
oh,
we must have one.
Something that,
that you resent.
Yes,
exactly.
All right,
well,
perfect transition bill.
We uh,
we picked up a couple of games here to break down with you.
Of course,
all the spreads coming from our official partner,
my bookie dot.
Aig.
He's that Promo Code Bill bets for 100% deposit bonus.
First game opening game of the season.
Atlanta falcons heading into Philadelphia right now.
It's looking like eagles minus two and a half.
I think it opened at like three and a half.
It was up to four when it sounded like,
when says playing now when's is out?
Falls is named the starter.
Which way you lean in on this game.
Ah,
you got to take the eagles at home.
I know.
I,
you know they're going to be raising the flag.
Every one's going to be going nuts.
Half the crowd will be in that little jail they have.
Um,
I,
ah,
it is,
it's still the eagle.
So those should win this game,
but there's still until they,
when that second one,
this still the eagles,
but I'm going to take the eagles at home considering,
uh,
nick falls had a pedestrian 300 yards in the Superbowl
compared to Tom Brady's 500 yards and losing,
which will never be broken unless Tom less.
Tom Does it again.
Thank you so much for bringing this up.
Thank you so much.
I go at it with Patriots fans who say that Brady had a better game,
that false.
Now,
Brady had an amazing game and you can't obviously knock Brady's play at all,
but in that particular game I would say nick foals out play them because of the
couple key plays fulls made and the limiting of the turnovers and Brady
obviously.
Yeah,
Sean's defensive of Nick fold is a passion of mine and Brady obviously.
What?
Well No,
and then the fumble,
that kind of turned the game at the end.
On the other side,
you've got nick foals driving down to get a touchdown.
Now I'm not trying to time out too.
First of all,
Tom Brady's not a running back.
He's like 51 years old.
If you don't block and he gets tackled that one fumble duty true for 500 yards.
If you're really going to put it,
it was our defense.
He fix.
What's the problem on both sides of the ball?
Both sides of the ball.
Nick false came out like it was a regular season game.
He wasn't nervous.
Tom Brady's Tom Brady.
Balsa offenses play great.
That defenses on both teams sucked.
The only thing was the eagle sucked a little less.
They,
he goes basically the eagles made the only,
I think defensive play the game.
You all I'm saying,
listen,
you started this shit.
I sit there congratulating you.
If you're going to say like,
like that is like,
like some ESPN shit to say like somebody how takes gone.
Somebody throws to a 500 yards and they're the problem.
They they I think Carol kind of offs.
Yeah.
Tom didn't have the
magic.
No.
I,
at this point it's my,
it's probably my second favorite sport.
Watching Sean talked about how Nicole's had a better game than Tom Brady and to
be clear,
Tom Brady had an amazing gape.
The reason the patriots lost was because they couldn't stop anyone on defense.
That's,
that's what I'm not really what you're bringing it full circle for us.
Nick Nicole's is going to suck like he has the rest of his career and the,
but also like eagles couldn't stop the patriots either.
They stopped him one fucking to do.
There was like two pumps the whole game.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
There's no talking shit about what your defense did in that game other than we
made one play.
The offense was,
it was the weirdest.
I can't watch it because it's too still too close,
but I have to go back and watch it.
It's the weirdest fucking game.
I mean at this,
that's,
that's some shit that happens at like division three high school where it's like
two pumps in a game.
He looked like a big game.
It was really,
uh,
it was,
it was bizarre.
I not start yet.
Um,
and it started off with what's his face is like,
like,
like crying,
like he's had a funeral.
Malcolm Butler.
Oh Man.
What did he do?
I guess we'll never find,
I should've known.
I should've known when he was,
when they'd better.
Anytime Bella check does that we lose.
So I remember we were playing the jets at home and Wes Welker had made all those
feet joke about Rex Ryan.
We sat him and then Brady threw the worst passivist career on that.
That screen pass or it was just,
it was like he threw it three yard hail.
Mary went up in the air and it's always a pick six.
And uh,
so anyway,
what happened man,
I wish that you guys beat somebody else because I was very happy.
I would have what?
I could have enjoyed watching the eagles.
Finally,
what am I,
because I don't wish long term misery on any sports fan other than a select stu,
you,
Montreal,
Montreal Canadians fans and Yankee fence to everybody else.
Everybody else.
All right.
So Kramer said,
what are you,
uh,
are you,
are you going with,
obviously I'm going to be on the eagles.
The key with foals is if you give him time,
if he,
if he doesn't face a pass for us,
she's going to be okay.
They got Jason Peters coming back and left tackle.
I think that'll be huge.
They get some of their weapons back.
I think they could scheme up a decent game plan.
I think their defense will play good,
uh,
against the Falcons here week one.
And uh,
yeah,
they're raising the banners.
I think there'll be jacked for it.
I'm going on the eagles.
You got shut down the vikings,
you know everybody,
you guys just completely shut them down in the,
in the NFC championship game if I remember correctly.
So they'll,
the census there,
I just don't,
that was like a twilight zone game.
It was bizarre because I every scenario in my head going over the game for the
eagles to when it was going to be a defensive struggle,
you know,
or,
or a low scoring game.
I certainly didn't see 13 yeah,
something like that.
That's what I was thinking and I was shocked to see them pull it out with the,
you know,
74 points or whatever scored.
Yeah,
I mean listen,
it's tough go against the the,
I mean the Patriots got run up last year,
but typically the team raising the banner,
it's a good bet.
You know,
the contrarian in me also likes the line,
the line move is moving the wrong way.
Nick falls did just win the Superbowl MVP.
So gotta give them the benefit of the doubt.
But what I would say the Falcons could have that pass for a show and you
mentioned the pass rush.
That could be the problem.
And just out of principle off,
I'm of course I'm going to fade the eagles fair niggles.
All right.
Next up,
big game.
Houston Texans at the New England patriots right now.
Patriots six point favorite.
And uh,
I'll kick things off.
I like to Pat's here,
lane six against his texts and his team.
I mean one thing that's been pretty consistent in the Brady Bella check era is
they look good coming off a loss.
And if you look at 2012 when they lost the Superbowl in 2008 they and even back
to the parcels and 96,
they came back and uh,
they want 34 13 they want 1710 they won 41 to seven.
Like this team,
I think we'll come out with a statement game and really put it on the tech since
that's what I mean,
I'm not trying to be a jerk here,
but how does,
how does that have anything to do with this team?
All those and all of the personnel from all of that.
It's like,
you know,
they,
they play really good historically and when it's 70 degrees out,
Bella check I guess.
Yeah,
I guess,
I guess to me it's,
I don't spell checks.
The guy that just doesn't lose back to back games and I think,
listen,
little brothers coming off coming off a Superbowl loss.
Yeah.
Bill O'brien,
former guy in the coaching tree.
I think he's going to want to put it on him.
I just,
this patriots team seems like they're ready to make a statement at home against
the Texans team.
How do you see it go?
Well,
I think that Texas quarterback,
what's his name there to Sean Watson?
He's coming off the ACL.
He's going to be a nightmare.
He's going to be a nightmare for us trying to contain him.
And the only thing I like is like,
I guess they have the worst offensive line in the league.
I think that bodes well for us.
Um,
what's the spread?
Six patriots lane six at home.
Oh,
they always pick the perfect number.
Dot.
Yeah.
They're so good.
You know what?
I'm going to dope.
I'm actually,
I'm actually going to take the Texans with the points because you have the last
year we played the Kansas City chiefs and they came in and they killed us.
And I'm so I'm gonna play your game and talk about something that happened
before.
Probably doesn't matter.
I think everybody's going to jump on the patch being like,
oh,
they're going to be pissed because they've lost the super bowl.
Everything you just said.
And then the time Julio Jones,
that wasn't really,
you're at a sports bar like me who don't have jobs and make a couple of great
catches in.
Now also,
this is the revenge game.
I'll forget.
They haven't seen us since we,
uh,
came back and this,
you know,
came back historically two years ago in the Superbowl against them.
So,
uh,
I guess going to,
sorry,
I think you're bringing the falcons in there for a second right there?
No,
we were playing Texas.
Oh,
sorry.
good.
Kramer.
Which way?
Which way you lean in here?
Uh,
I mean,
yeah,
it's Bellicheck just whoops.
On his disciples period.
Yeah,
not much.
The handicap to Sean Watson would scare me with that defense.
Yeah,
I do.
I am curious to see the offensive line,
but I've just seen,
I feel like we've seen this so many times where a t and optimistic disciple of
bill Bellacheck comes in and just gets,
gets a shit pushed in.
So yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not saying the Patriots week one.
Yeah,
I do.
I do think bill is hitting on something.
No,
because I feel like,
and maybe this is again just kind of a gut instinct,
but the pats kind of play themselves in September.
They,
they use it as an extended preseason,
kind of tried some stuff,
figure out some things.
And I'm still shocked that Patricia got a head coaching job because I don't know
that defense didn't want,
you know,
instill a lot of confidence.
So that's,
that's crazy that he got that Detroit Gig.
Y'All can't reminds me of when I first moved out to la the first time it'll late
nineties.
Everybody out here either had a Seinfeld or a friend's credit and that entitled
them to some sort of show runner like,
or Dave,
we get some sort of deal and they would pair them up like,
oh,
this guy wrote on friends,
this guy wrote on Samsung.
I think bill Bellacheck is the Seinfeld of writers' room.
If you did,
if you did anything,
if you were the waterboy yeah,
but he was the water boy bill Bellacheck you don't make a lateral move.
You don't become the waterboy you,
you get elevated in physicians.
So maybe that's why a Patricia's where we,
yes.
I mean it's so true,
but it sounds like Patricia is just,
it sounds like people are already penciling them in as a failure.
It sounds like things aren't going well.
There's some weird dynamics going on with that team.
All right.
One of the,
uh,
one of the Monday night games.
There's the dual Monday night game.
Do a kick off the season,
which fuck it.
Why not the La Rams head up to Oakland right now.
The Raiders four point home dog bill.
I'll let you,
uh,
get things cause started here.
How do you,
how do you see this game shaken out?
Do you look?
Do you like the Raiders?
What's your thoughts on John Gruden?
MMM,
I'm hoping that he doesn't regret going back to the 24,
seven,
three 65 life of coaching when I always feel like when coaches get into
broadcasting and there was good at good at it as is groupness they gotta be
sitting there going like this,
just job as a joke compared to what?
Compared to what I used to have to do.
But I imagine he missed it.
Obviously they getting the right amount of money.
He came back,
I mean Gruden I know he's been gone for a while,
man.
I mean,
well how many years?
Like almost a decade and a half.
He left like early two thousands.
Am I right?
Yeah,
I think it's good.
At least 10 years.
I think we looked it up.
It was,
it was before the wildcat.
So to put that in perspective.
Yeah.
So that's a long time and each generation of kids is a little bit different and
he's also rebuilding and uh,
I saw the thing on the Ram's head coach where he could recall like,
you,
you see that in real sports with Bryant Gumbel.
Like they'd be like,
Hey,
a minute,
42,
week eight,
third quarter,
what happened?
He's like,
Oh yeah,
we ran that sweep play.
Uh,
the guard didn't get out,
uh,
quite where we wanted him to,
but he got the job done.
He has like a photographic memory.
I think that guy is,
is like,
if anybody's going to be the next generation of guys,
it's going to be him.
And um,
where he's,
where he's just taking the ramps so quickly.
I just think,
uh,
because gluten's just starting to put it back together,
I would take the ramps.
Okay.
Kramer,
first of all.
Yeah,
it comes off like somewhere between a serial killer and rain man and that piece,
he's definitely like,
well advanced of grew and,
and,
and just just imagine,
I mean,
I have to deal with millennials on a daily basis.
John,
I can not imagine John Gruden dealing with millennials.
I mean,
we know why he came back.
We saw it in hard knocks last year.
He still was making a playbook.
He just didn't have anyone to give it to.
He loves the racking,
the visors.
He's,
he's cut like half the team.
I think I saw that there's,
there's 31 new players on his 53 man roster.
Um,
I saw a great tweet.
The,
the Raiders decided to pay a coach $100 million and not pay their best player.
90.
Uh,
so many reasons to,
I mean,
this is the ultimate,
like,
just take the ugly dog,
right?
This is the ultimate,
take the ugly dog on Monday night,
but I,
I can't do it.
I can't do it in this spot.
So yeah,
I'm going to fake.
I come on,
we,
we think Jay Gruden's a joke.
At least I do.
He made a mistake,
he's gonna realize it quickly.
My talks,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't normally like to take a kind of road favorite here in a divisional
spot.
I,
I normally like to take a Monday night home dog.
Great Opportunity here.
But man,
this Raiders team is in crazy disarray and it just seems like the quarterbacks
pissed off.
He's upset that they traded their best player.
It's a weird move to pull this close to the season.
And the Raiders did the what,
24th ranked defense with Kaleel Mack.
You trade a all time defensive player.
Now maybe this will end up working out for them in the long run.
But I think this rams offense,
even though they didn't get a lot of reps in the pre season for whatever reason
McVay maybe,
you know they use the crazy analytics and some sports side,
no wig Gruden's using analytics.
He openly challenges analytics,
which I Kinda,
I normally like the old school guy approach there but uh,
yeah,
well I'm lucky.
Yeah,
half the shits and boxes.
Look at that.
You look at the ram season that last year in St Louis didn't go well,
moved out to Fisher.
It was just a complete disaster.
We just think of this,
if Joe like John Gruden became a caricature,
much like John Madden,
imagine if John Madden came back to coaching after like 15 years.
No fucking way.
Yeah.
I think burden.
Uh,
it'll be interesting.
I don't know.
I'm not that guy.
Can't coach.
I'm just saying he walked into a hell of a situation and he's playing these guys
week one who are just going to build on what they,
the past two seasons,
how much they've improved.
I just think they're,
I think they're going to keep going.
The rams have a lot of momentum from last year.
Not even catching like an east coast team play in that late kickoff.
You're catching another west coast team.
So it's not like they have no,
it's,
there might be more rare.
I mean there's gonna be a lot of rams fans right now that the bandwagon has
gotten nice and roomy.
Yeah,
I think it's,
I think it's just,
I don't see a lot of Ram fans going up to Oakland,
you know all those.
True.
That's also true for a picture show.
That is such a weird tradition.
You guys.
Let's get her costumes on and go to the game.
The foam spike shoulder pads like,
hey,
I got to,
we're going to go tailgate.
Let me stop off at Michael's first to get all my face pain and Styrofoam cones.
The glue on the shoulder pads.
I'm a pirate.
Yeah.
They used to look like a biker gang.
The crowd somewhere along the line.
Yes.
Starting to look like like a musical,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like,
like for kids,
even the scary things looks a little friendly.
It's almost like if kiss just became a cheering section.
Yeah.
It's like rocky horror pictures,
whatever the hell that stupid movie is meets like,
uh,
like needs like a Disney ride or something.
Like we can only make it so scary because we don't,
this is something about like when you have the dad bod
and foam spikes coming up.
I love that.
They think that they're intimidating.
The other team,
the other team literally has 300 pound guys trying to rip their heads off.
But you're up there dressed like a pirate and you're the one who's going to be
throw him off.
Oh,
you're eyepatch man,
you're freaking me out.
There's a lot of that.
The dog found a lot of that silly stuff.
Like,
you know,
your dad goes there on a rubber mask,
eat dog biscuits.
It's like,
come on dad,
I gotta go.
Cool.
On Monday.
I have to respect your father.
Come on.
Yeah,
you just helped me with my math homework.
You're not crazy.
All right bill,
before we,
uh,
before we let you go here,
what is a,
maybe it's these three games,
maybe it's a,
a,
another game you feel really strongly about week one.
Can we get you to throw out a lock?
You know,
we are gambling podcasts,
so what is,
what is bill burrs lead pipe lock for week one,
my lead pipe lock.
All right,
this is my lock and it's not going to be gambling related.
Yes,
my lock is going to be whatever happens this week.
Most people in sports are going to talk radio are going to act like,
you know,
like say Oakland gets their asses kicked,
all they're going to be talking about that John Gluten was Jacob was he sitting
on $100 million and he's,
and he's,
he's all in one worst case scenario,
one game out of first they're going to act like every goddamn thing that happens
this son Thursday,
Sunday and Monday is what's going to happen the whole year.
They do it every fucking year.
When Kansas City came out and checked the Patriots ass,
all of a sudden Kansas City was the fucking team of the future and what happened
to them?
You know,
the Patriots went back and won the AFC championship,
you know,
so I mean,
just don't listen for gamblers.
Do not listen to all of the freaking out that they're going to be doing when
they feel that it's just,
I don't know,
they always got asked like,
the fucking sky is falling or Jesus just came back after every single game.
You know what I mean?
You look at some of the teams that started to now and then get destroyed,
missed the playoffs.
And that's a great advice,
especially for gamblers because a lot of times you see one week and then
complete crazy overreactions and we always talk about that week too.
When you're picking your games,
don't overreact to that week one.
If you had a strong feeling or know whatever you,
you were really high on the team,
it could just be one bad game.
Don't totally throw out your shit by low Sean.
Bye.
Hello.
Exactly.
Look for the look for that overreaction spread.
If he can jump on that.
Tons of line value there.
And of course you can head over to my bookie.
Dot.
Agee to take advantage of that potential line value either week,
one week to live betting prop bets.
They got it all in game way during my bookie.
Dot.
Agee.
Use that Promo Code Bill bets for a 100% deposit bonus.
Bill,
appreciate calling in man and uh,
we'll talk to you soon.
Thanks dude.
All right guys,
go pass.
I'll see it
later.
Souls.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper.
It's the Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
September 6th,
2010 happy Labor Day to one and all to all the laborers out there.
All right.
God bless you if you got a job,
God bless you.
If you're looking for a job and if he just sitting on your ass and you're not
doing either,
um,
how do you get away with it?
Cause that's what I want to do.
You know?
Isn't that the dream?
That's my dream in life to work.
If I choose to just fucking lay around all day and just be like,
you know what?
I am so sick of fucking lay in round.
I think today I'm going to go down and put some hubcaps down on a fucking Ford
Fairmont.
You know,
maybe that's what I'll do.
What do you guys doing for Labor Day?
Huh?
You guys boozed at this point,
I'm a little bit late with the podcast.
It's four 16 east coast time when I'm recording this.
Hi.
Have you already gotten drunk?
Had it out with your brother,
you know,
after three beers she did that,
that paranoia that your mom loved him better starts creeping in and all of a
sudden you guys get out there for a little fun game of volleyball and all of a
sudden real quickly,
it's not fun is it?
Huh?
You staring at him through that net,
that fucking transparent fucking screen.
You can see through it,
but you can't penetrate it.
Kind of like the fucking ice cold personality of your mom.
You know,
she'd never quite let you in.
So what do you do?
You bury your sorrows and fucking alcohol on Labor Day.
Happy Labor Day,
happy Labor Day,
getting shit faced,
eating some shit.
Hate in your fucking life.
The next day at work.
That's a new labor day song.
Everybody,
it might sound familiar,
but it's a,
it's cause it's so catchy.
It's not a Christmas song.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
actually I was sitting here wondering,
you know,
bit being,
um,
as it's,
it's Labor Day.
Labor Day is another one of those days.
Um,
that I just don't understand the history behind it.
Like,
I don't,
I don't know shit about flag day.
I don't shit about Labor Day.
I don't know.
I don't understand Columbus Day,
you know,
is that the day that he thought he landed in America?
But he was actually down in the,
in the fucking Caribbean.
Then he started making them dig up diamonds that weren't there.
So we started cutting their fucking hands off.
Is that,
is that why we have a day off on Columbus Day?
Huh?
I understand Memorial Day.
That's for the troops.
Anybody laid down their life or even served.
I get that one Easter.
That's when the bunny comes.
Here comes Peter cottontail hopping down the bunny trail.
Hippity hoppity Easter's on its way.
That's one of the widest songs ever.
So I would like to apologize to all the non whites out there for wherever.
Whatever white guy wrote that song,
bragging all his Easter,
Jill.
Something like a basket full of me.
They actually sit there and that song and this something like he's got jelly
beads for Bobby colored eggs.
Four sisters sue.
He's got nothing for Yolanda.
Now.
What's,
what's,
what's a Tayshawn?
There's nothing in there.
No candy for any,
any,
anything like that,
you know,
do [inaudible] Kim,
he doesn't get any fucking Easter grass,
does he?
He doesn't even get the grass at the bottom of the basket and that fucking song,
you know.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
So I was wondering what is he,
what is he history of Labor Day?
Because I'm a nerd and a so let me,
let me read you guys a little bit of history.
Labor Day.
How did Labor,
Labor,
Kumu,
Hildy um,
this has been the history of Labor Day in the United States.
Dates back to September 5th,
1882 in New York City,
uh,
in accordance with the plans of the central labor union.
I really feel like a history teacher right now and you guys are all starting to
zone out and I'm standing up there with dockers with chalk dust on the front of
them,
but 80,
18,
84,
um,
the first Monday of September was selected as the holiday to celebrate wherever
day,
trying to have even more annoying,
fortunate as originally proposed by the union.
This is all going to be on attached tax next week.
So I hope you guys are all taking notes.
So it's done just not to wherever you and your nerves,
similar organizations and other shit is to follow the example of New York to
celebrate a workman's holiday.
Sorry,
I'm back on that date.
So basically it started in New York City and then with the growth of labor
unions and the pressure that they then were able to apply to the ruling class,
they then tried to make it a national holiday and they finally did.
They made it a federal holiday.
This is really interesting why they did it.
Not because they were like,
yeah,
you know what?
We got these guys working their asses off all week.
They're in these dank fucking apartments getting tuberculosis as we sit out here
in our fucking manners.
Why not give them one fucking day off?
This is when they finally did it was following the deaths of numerous,
a number of workers at the hands of the u s military and us marshals during the
Pullman strike.
So basically,
uh,
you know,
they were fighting to get a decent,
decent wage and they brought in the u s military,
which is really,
you know,
it's like what the,
what the fuck's it wants to deal with Lewin,
you know,
US military supposed to protect us.
I thought that those guys were on our side.
No,
they worked for the rich.
They,
you go and whether you fuck with the rich in this country overseas or here,
they will send in the military to fuck you up.
And US marshals cops also.
So,
uh,
yeah,
basically because they went so over,
they cross such a fucking huge line by actually killing workers and that they
were worried that we were going to storm.
They're fucking mansions.
They said,
all right,
we'll give them one fucking day off.
All right.
Goddamn cons.
Right.
And President Grover Cleveland,
he's a guy who moved it in.
He put it into a action there.
And Grover Cleveland actually,
who just looks like the most boring human being on the planet.
He actually looks like out of nowhere.
He gets catchy with the joke and he would deliver it totally dead pan.
You just catch that twinkle in his eye of who we used to be before he got
married and had to listen to some fucking broad,
tell them how to give his goddamn speeches to the union.
He actually holds the title of the only president to serve two terms,
but not consecutively.
Hence he is the 22nd and 24th president of the United States.
Did you know that?
Well,
why don't you break that out at your Labor Day fucking barbecue?
Huh?
You know,
he looks like he looks like that guy in uh,
was that Ron Howard movie about the old people doing cannon balls in the pool
cocoon.
He looks like that guy also.
He did the diabetes commercial something with a w I got no fucking idea.
So anyways,
yeah,
this is the Monday morning podcast for a Monday.
Uh,
what the fuck?
September 6th.
There we go.
I got so much shit.
I'm trying.
I give like literally 12 fucking windows open on my laptop right now.
My laptop is sitting in my lap radiating my nuts.
Yeah.
How so?
Someday in the future I can be on 60 minutes talking about how the wind just
blows right through my clock.
My crotch getting divided by my Dick because I no longer have balls.
And if you're wondering why,
why can't my balls take it but my Dick can because my dick is that fucking
strong.
All right.
The balls are the weak point of my unit.
You know,
it's kind of like a muscle car.
Hey fuck it.
It's great.
But just in a straight line.
That's what my Dick is like a speaking of which last week I shot a pilot and I
rented a dodge challenger and I was unbelievably fucking frustrated trying to
drive that car out here.
I didn't even get the one with the hammer.
I just got one with the six cylinder,
which felt like it had a Hemi after getting out of my fucking Prius and um,
I've decided I'm not going to get that car.
I'm just waiting for everybody to Groan.
Oh,
Bell Bell.
Don't give up on your dream.
I haven't given up on it,
but there's just,
there's nowhere to drive it out here.
You know,
this is what a fucking dodge challenger sounds like in the middle of Nebraska.
This is what it sounds like.
An La,
oh blah,
blah,
blah.
Fucking go
that.
That's all I did.
I'll fuck a week.
There was nowhere to go with the fucking thing.
I get on the highway,
some fucking truck driver in the left lane,
cause there's no god damn rules out here.
It's like,
do you you,
you play the game tetris.
That's,
that's what driving a car is like out here.
There's no like there's no,
there's nowhere to go.
There's just always this cascade of shit just coming at you and that there's no
way to drive the car.
And I've just decided it's the stupidest fucking thing you could ever do out
here.
So now I'm thinking,
I don't know,
maybe I'll get a good old car that just a cruiser,
you know,
like a Malibu or a Chevelle,
maybe an impala.
Just something I could just of have a little style
as a cab.
My arm out the window drive 25 fucking miles an hour out here.
If anybody lives in La and you actually have a fast car,
can you tell me what you drive it?
You got a fast car.
Remember that?
Remember when Whoopi Goldberg wrote that Song.
We look,
get it fan as well.
Get a car and we'll drive away.
A lot of people don't remember that would be Goldberg was actually a singer
early in her career and she sang that song a fast car.
Uh,
actually it wasn't whoopie Goldberg.
It was Tracy Chapman,
Tracy Chapman who looked a lot like Larry Holmes.
Um,
that was really fucking mean.
Oh,
you know,
what do you want from me?
I'm 10 minutes in and I'm feeling like,
uh,
I'm running out of energy.
You know what it is?
I'm in holiday mode the same way you guys were Friday,
Friday afternoon,
you had your feet up on your plastic fucking desk.
And uh,
that's how I feel right now.
So actually listen to this,
everybody,
I've finally figured out a way where I can make a little bit money off of this
podcast.
It's not going to break the bank and I can take the money and buy this recorder
that cost about six,
700 bucks.
That would actually allow me to drive around and record podcasts like I did back
in the day.
Um,
every once in a while.
Do that just to switch it up because I get bored being in my apartment after a
while.
So this is the deal.
Um,
I was trying to,
you know,
come up with something I didn't want to charge for the podcast and I also want
to give people the,
uh,
the option of donating to the podcast.
So basically this is what we came up with.
We came up with a ringtone and,
uh,
the ringtone is,
Oh gee,
all right,
it's 99 cents.
You go to the MM podcast.com.
You Click on that page,
you need to look right on the left hand,
the left hand corner,
the top column.
I might as well go to the,
the uh,
the podcast right now.
You just click on that and you pay for it through paypal.
It's 99 cents.
Um,
you can't,
if you have a flip phone,
don't fucking do it because you're not going to be able to upload it to your
phone.
Uh,
but if you have any one of these smart phones,
I believe that they're called.
Um,
you can upload it right to your phone.
All it is is 99 cents.
Now I know all you fucking computer savvy people are out there.
Like,
dude,
I could just make a fucking,
you know a god damn ringtone.
I know you can I get it.
I know your kid.
Um,
hang on a second.
What the fuck am I going to,
I know you can do that shit.
This is just a God damn donation.
That's all it is.
Okay.
So I know you can make your own fucking ring tone,
but this is just to donate to the podcast.
All right?
So basically what you do is you go to the Monday morning podcast and uh,
if you look in the left hand corner,
it says get there and underneath pages you see,
Oh
gee,
she's right under the home.
So all you do is you just click on it,
takes you right to paypal,
cost you 99 cents,
99 cents people for three years of fucking podcast.
How about jumping on board and donating 99 cents?
I'm going to buy better equipment.
All right.
And uh,
and then basically what you can do is you can assign that ringtone to the
biggest pain in the ass in your life.
Be it your boss,
your,
your girlfriend,
your boyfriend,
your mom,
your dad,
your fucking landlord.
Anybody,
whoever's the biggest fucking cunt in your life.
This will give you a warning because it won't just Rick.
Okay?
It'll be sitting there on the coffee table and all of a sudden you see,
oh Jeez,
oh Jeez.
Oh Jeez.
And then he can laugh and be like,
I am not answering that shit.
And he can go back to drinking.
So that's set people.
There you go.
And this is deal.
If you don't want to get it,
don't fucking get it,
you know,
but you want to get it.
Go ahead and get it.
Typical thanks to the podcast is basically technically free.
I'm just asking for a donation.
99 fucking sense.
Can you look,
look into your heart.
You guys ever see that Miller's crossing?
It's one of my favorite fucking monologues of all time.
I watched that again the other night.
Ah,
yeah.
If you want to do it,
go ahead and do it.
If not,
I get it.
It's a tough economy.
99 fucking sense.
Don't be a con.
Go on there.
Download it.
Put it on your phone.
That'll put a smile on your face.
Just like the podcast does every Monday.
Now I'm getting you for the whole fucking week.
And there's another thing too.
If you guys have anything else you'd like me to do.
Any other uh,
ringtones,
if you'd like me to do the girl voice.
Hey Guy.
What is this relationship going?
Anything like that,
you know,
for your girlfriend,
from we have a dump voice for your boyfriend.
Any of that shit,
we can actually make a couple of more ringtones.
Um,
you know,
and this is just something every once in a while just like,
uh,
what are those where the PBS station,
you know,
every six months they're like,
oh my God,
we're going broke,
you know,
by these fucking Doo wop cds.
Basically.
This is what I'll do every six months or three months,
whatever.
However you guys will determine it.
How popular you like,
I mean,
basically 99 cents.
I think I could do it every month,
every two months or whatever.
Give you guys some custom ringtones here for your phones.
And,
um,
and you know,
and being people,
you're gonna have friends here.
You,
uh,
you know,
hear your ringtone.
It'd be like,
where did you get that?
Uh,
don't tell him,
don't tell him where you got it.
Just be like,
Eh,
it's too long a fucking story.
That way.
The podcast,
you know,
remains kind of underground the way I like it.
I'll make it a little bit of cash,
99 cents at a fucking time.
And,
uh,
who knows,
you know,
we,
there's other talks about coming up with some other,
uh,
merchandise for the podcast every once in awhile,
maybe once a year,
maybe around holidays.
Who knows
what,
but,
uh,
as of right now,
there you go.
The Oh Geez is fucking ringtone.
Um,
is now available@themmpodcast.com the official fan page of the Monday morning
podcasts,
a buddy of mine students,
and I don't name names in the pot,
Jess is doing such a bang up fucking job on it.
The podcast page looks unbelievable.
They just redid it.
Again,
it's got all the youtube videos,
everything you can,
if you're,
if you're a a,
an absolute,
um,
uh,
Monday morning podcast freak and you like every and you,
and you're also a neat freak and he liked everything nice and concise.
Go to the [inaudible],
podcast.com Yada,
Yada,
Yada.
There you go.
So that they,
that was painless,
right?
You know,
I thought of a million.
Thanks.
You know,
maybe the refrigerator magnet will actually be coming.
Um,
I might design one of those the Monday cause I've,
I've joked about,
I used to joke about that.
Me and Derosa did,
uh,
back on the uninformed show.
And uh,
we still always joke about shit like that,
but enough about that crap.
Let's get,
let's get to the funny.
All right.
That was the money.
Now we're back to the funniest fucking rhymed and I'm amazed at that.
Um,
let's get to some questions here.
Bill,
I have a question for you.
I know from the podcast that you played the drums and I had a couple of
questions for you.
I'm 22 and have really been itching to pick up the pick up an instrument and it
seems like nowadays everyone plays guitar.
I was wondering when you started playing the drums,
how you got started playing,
did you take lessons?
I guess I'm trying to find out where to start out.
Uh,
all right,
great questions.
Um,
I actually didn't start until I was 20.
I always loved music,
but um,
my dad,
uh,
is an unbelievable musician,
but he had music like forced on them.
So,
uh,
he views,
you know,
he kind of viewed,
I dunno,
giving us instruments the way I view,
you know,
if I ever have kids,
I'm taking them to organized religion,
some sort of church.
I just,
you know,
just something I had a bad experience with it so I stayed away so he didn't
really introduce.
So we just sort of gradually found it.
And I kind of grew up in a jock towns.
Everybody played sports.
So I did that.
So I didn't start till I was 20.
Um,
and I think,
I dunno,
I was watching the fuck made me start.
I know I was watching the iron maiden,
a VHS tape,
um,
whatever the,
I can't remember what the hell it was called.
It was the power slave tour.
And I saw Nico Mcbrain and uh,
they actually were behind him and I saw all four limbs going and he had those
drums totally surrounding him.
And I just thought it was the coolest fucking,
what I liked about it because I grew up playing sports.
It looked really physical.
The fact that every limb was involved and uh,
you know,
the drummer is always seemed crazy.
They always fucking Badass.
So that started me wanting to get into it.
And then I discovered led Zeppelin,
I discovered led Zepplin really late.
Okay.
Um,
I started working in a warehouse 1920,
right around the same time,
I guess 18.
It took me two years.
And then I finally,
I got totally into John Bonham and,
um,
I dunno,
I remember Bonnie Raitt of all fucking people described okay.
Why people play instruments.
And it was basically because watching someone play an instrument isn't enough
for you.
You,
you have to know how to fucking do it.
And obviously someone at her level,
yeah.
Takes it to an on,
you know,
actually learns how to write songs.
I'm Marla,
I'm at the total geek level.
MMM.
So that,
that's basically why I learned how to play.
And I just,
I started out like every other fucking,
uh,
white rock drummer.
We all listened to ACDC.
It's the most basic beat and,
and in
learn how to play with those things.
And then I moved on to who that was the next guy,
I think.
Then I moved on to Steven Adler,
guns and roses,
and then I went onto John Bonham and that was like the three levels that I kinda
went to.
Then I started,
yes,
I took lessons,
but you don't even need to take lessons.
You could literally go onto youtube and um,
just type in beginner drum lessons.
I mean you can learn in six months what it took me five years to learn.
And a,
if there's a song you're trying to figure out,
just type,
type in the song,
kickstart my heart,
um,
drum lesson.
No,
there is no drum lesson.
Just write drum cover and you can watch somebody play it.
And um,
a guy that I loved is something called down Mike's lessons.com.
This guy out of Sacramento who's just,
he's a fucking beast and he's not afraid of other drummers who are beasts and he
brings him in.
He actually does live drum lessons.
MMM.
I actually signed up for him and I forgot my fucking password.
So I've never been able to,
I haven't been able to watch one in forever.
Um,
but he's got a ton of,
uh,
drummer videos,
every,
everything from beginner,
intermediate,
all that shit.
And right now I'm fucking with something.
Do you want to see if even if you guys aren't into this drummer shit,
I know this might be kind of boring until you selfish cunt out there.
Who I'm not on a topic that you want me to talk about.
Dude,
love to podcast,
but enough about the drum and shit.
Um,
check out this Youtube Video Search Sha Gospel Chops.
Nice drum fill to help you out.
I've actually been a,
I can play that.
I just don't,
I don't understand.
I think he's playing six to any other drummers out there.
Can help me out.
Is he playing it like a 32nd note?
I can't remember.
It sounds like he starts at the end of four and ends on the end of one.
He starts it in a weird place and ends it in a weird place.
And then it seems like he plays the lick and then he plays the second half,
half of the lick over again.
Am I right?
I can't remember.
I actually,
I sat here for like fucking 20 minutes.
I just kept playing it over and over again.
Like fucking Jack Nicholson in a whatever that movie is,
where he fucking chops.
That guy scat man Crothers with the fucking ax.
The hell is that movie called Red Rum.
The shining.
I just sat there with that look on my face.
Just watching this kid over and over.
The,
I dunno,
there's so many talented fucking people.
So that's what I would do.
Just go out and get a drum kit.
If you live in an apartment,
I'd get those electronic drum kits,
uh,
go on Ebay.
Um,
and,
and get an electronic drum kit,
get the v drums,
they're the best,
and set them up in your apartment basically,
and then go to,
I'm gonna break the whole fucking thing down to you.
Go to toys r us and get those little,
those,
those little foam,
you know,
people who are like so paranoid that their kids actually going to fall down at
some point in discover that gravity exists.
And if you fall down,
it actually hurts for some reason.
They don't want them to learn that lesson.
They want them to feel like when you fall down on a hardwood floor,
it feels like you're in one of those fucking inflatable castles that they have
at their little birthday parties.
They got these little foam rubber things,
they're about a half inch thick and they fit together like jigsaw puzzles.
And these over-protective psycho fucking parents of today were literally by him
and fill up their entire play room with them.
So every time they fall down,
you know,
they bounce right back up and then shit into their diaper without missing a
fucking step.
You get those?
I actually get to levels of them.
And if you have somebody who lives underneath you,
um,
and you just get them big enough with a whole drum kit fits on it.
So all the vibration goes right into those things.
And if you want to be a total solid guy,
what I used to do in New York was I would,
I would knock on the door of the neighbor beneath me,
introduce myself,
tell them that it played drums.
Um,
if they just asked him what is your work schedule?
And most of them worked nine to five.
I say I play two hours a day.
I'll only play between nine hours of nine and five.
Here is my home phone number.
If you're ever home when I play,
call me up and I will stop immediately and then you won't have any,
if you have fucking problems after that,
you live over the biggest country ever and you need to download that ringtone.
And every time they go to call you,
you got to have o g,
G and then don't answer it and continue fucking plank.
All right,
there we go.
I know Jesus Christ.
I'm explaining Labor Day and explaining drum shit.
Any and that goes for any instrument to you guys.
If you guys want to learn how to play any fucking instrument,
basically,
guitar,
Bass,
drums,
any of that shit,
piano,
anything.
Just go out,
buy a buy a cheap version of the instrument just so you make sure you're going
to stick with it and just go on youtube and start learning how to play songs
that you like.
And next thing you know,
you'll be the hit at your Christmas party plane journey songs.
Um,
this is actually making me want to go play,
go play drums right now.
Check out those Gospel Chop Drummers,
those guys,
they're fucking unreal like that.
The stuff that they've come up with,
then it's really,
I dunno when you,
it's absolutely brilliant,
but it's also like,
it's kind of simple after a while when you kind of figure out what they're
doing.
If you could just hear,
what if it's 30 seconds or 16th note triplets and then kind of,
it's just broken up between the hands and feet and it just sounds like they're
going 9 million miles an hour,
but it's because they add the bass drum.
I don't know.
It's fucking genius.
Um,
all right,
enough about that shit.
All right,
let's get to,
somebody wrote me a a,
an email this week and evidently they got a little bit offended by something
that I said,
said,
Bill,
I've listened to your podcast for three years now religiously.
I've also come to see many of your live shows many times and brought your DVDs
and your cds.
Okay,
so this person,
as always,
is establishing what a big fan they are and how much they've supported me.
However,
I was listening to your podcast from the 28th of August and I have to say that I
am completely and utterly disgusted.
I could not believe that you could say something.
This disgraceful,
this,
this disgraceful.
The comment said was even Rick flair couldn't do fake kicks better than Robert
Deniro.
Oh,
that's when I was talking about when he was kicking Bob,
Billy batts.
How dare you criticize the way the nature boy kicked someone.
How you're really going to call out the greatest wrestler of all time and the
leader of the four horsemen from this day forth forth.
I will never listen to your podcast or buy a ticket to see,
see you or by one of your DVDs.
Again,
I hope ric flair sees you and flare chops you write in that pasty chest of
yours.
I could only imagine how long the mark would be ingrained into your chest.
And then he gives a ric flair quote.
I'm a limousine riding jet flying kiss,
stealing wheel the wheel and deal in son of a gun.
Woo.
Thanks.
From a former listener,
of course that guy was just fucking around.
I had to read that because that was textbook.
Um,
that almost followed exactly along the lines of when somebody is actually truly
offended and not fucking around.
The only thing that you didn't put in the beginning of it is you need to
demonstrate what a big sense of humor you have.
And then everyone around you says,
you know
what a big fun.
You know what a great fucking sense of humor you have.
I've actually had a couple of these.
I had mock people being offended with me.
I think that this is maybe a new,
uh,
a new segment here on the podcast.
Here's one out.
Dear Mr. Burn.
I guess I should state upfront that I'm a huge comedy fan who likes all sorts of
comedy and nothing ever offends me.
Classic,
classic intro.
You stuck the landing sir.
Um,
and he goes,
he goes,
since that's how a whiny bitch complaints start.
Whiny bitch complaint things starts,
isn't it?
People,
I have to apologize how boring this fucking podcast is and how much I'm
stuttering.
Okay.
I'm a little fucking burned out.
Last week,
um,
I shot my pilot for comedy central with,
uh,
that costars Kevin Hart,
who if you don't know who he is,
you got to check him out.
He's one of the funniest fucking dudes I've ever met at a,
after working with him for a week,
just watching him act and all this stuff that he brings,
he is really with,
he's the real deal man.
Just to fucking a,
he's a fucking star man.
So I'm really psyched to be doing this show and we were working 12 hour days,
so I'm a little burned out here.
Um,
I basically want to be sitting in a bar right now,
getting shit faced.
That's what I want to do in celebration of all you guys out there actually have
real jobs as opposed to mine,
which is a fucking joke.
But last week I actually got to feel what it feels like to work a 12 hour
workday,
like most of you people.
And um,
as much fun as it is,
you know,
I'm,
I'm out of shape.
I am not in working shape.
I have to admit
I do whatever the fuck it is I want to do.
My life is ridiculously awesome and I really don't take it for granted.
You know,
I don't,
but for some reason I'm still busy every day because you know,
it's one of those deals when you work for yourself,
you still have to,
uh,
you know,
you're the only one rowing the boat.
That's the only way to put it.
So you gotta you gotta keep rolling.
You got to row a couple of miles every day or else you just fucking sick.
But,
uh,
the great thing is,
is,
you know,
any day that I do feel like just fucking,
I can,
I decide when I have a fucking day off.
That's what I like about it rather than when I worked for people and they,
and they were like,
you know,
wanted me to get all excited that I had a three day fucking weekend,
which I did back in the day.
But now I get to be like,
you know what,
I think I'm going to fucking go out this afternoon and go see my check.
I saw that movie.
You guys see it yet.
You got to go see machete,
machete a machete.
You got to go see that fucking thing.
Uh,
I absolutely loved it over the top violence and,
um,
they have one of the great over the top violence scenes I've ever fucking seen.
I'm not going to ruin it,
but I give it a thumbs up.
I recommend it.
Um,
go there to have fun,
to see over the top violence and to go see a great tribute to a B
slasher slash like fucking action movie to Goddamn great movie.
Um,
anyways,
let's continue here with the mediocre podcast.
Whatever.
It's a day off,
right?
You don't give a shit.
I,
you know,
I bet a lot of you guys wanting to complain about this podcast.
She just psyched you have the fucking day off.
I'm probably going to get more complaints from people overseas.
You know,
we have to go to work with they're crooked teeth.
Um,
that's my view of a lot of other other countries.
They have fucked up teeth,
they have great healthcare,
but they're teeth are fucked up.
You know,
we have nationwide healthcare really?
Well,
why don't you go use it,
you know,
at
the very least,
why don't you brush your teeth like fucking twice a day?
Like a normal person.
You know,
she's didn't a walking around here looking like Dracula,
drank too much fucking coffee.
Um,
um,
so I was listening to the podcast a couple of weeks ago on my,
on my way to work,
laughing away.
It's something astoundingly racist or sexist.
You had said,
um,
really?
I'll definitely say something sexist.
I probably said something racial,
but I don't think it was racist.
I would've gotten more or less unless I was defending Dr Laura.
My timing could not be any worse this fucking week.
I want us because if I,
I didn't do standup all last week.
Maybe that's what it is.
It's like going to the gym and been in the gym for a while,
whatever,
you know what I mean?
Pick a great fucking,
let's look at ACDC.
You know what I mean?
Blow up your video.
Fly on the wall there.
They had some stinkers out there.
This is my,
uh,
yeah.
This is my blow up your video podcast.
What are we 31 minutes.
Jesus Christ.
This is hilarious.
Labor Day.
Everybody has a fucking day off and here I am staring at the clock like I'm at
work.
Anyways,
Bill,
let me try and see if I,
if I read this slower,
if I can actually make this mildly amusing.
You mentioned you received an email from New Zealand and said you would start,
uh,
stating your favorite people from different countries starting with New Zealand,
New Zealand.
Imagine my anticipation is I waited to see what awesome Kiwi you are about to
give a shout out to.
I'm a proud Kiwi who has lived out of the country
for work reasons.
Oh for nearly 10 years.
So every little piece of home means something to me.
And then you say Phil Rudd,
I guess I said Phil Run is the coolest guy from New Zealand.
Um,
because I knew he lived there,
so I assumed that he actually was from New Zealand.
So the guy said Phil Rudd.
Phil Rudd is from Melbourne,
Australia.
While we here from New Zealand would be incredibly happy to have been
responsible for the creators of some of the greatest rock and roll of all time.
I couldn't in good conscious take that away from the city I lived in for the
last nine and a half a year.
Oh,
so you live in Melbourne.
Okay.
Where they are so proud of that band.
They named a street after them.
Seriously.
ACDC lane.
It's a dodgy little lane right in the center of the city.
I went to Melbourne.
When the fuck did they do that?
I would've got a touristy picture in front of that.
I told you guys that shit.
When I went to Australia,
I bought every,
um,
only available in Australia.
Um,
ACDC album.
They had the original TNT album,
which was the original high voltage that had dirty deeds on it.
I bought another one album that was called let there be rock.
Um,
I'll wait a minute.
They had an album called that there be rock,
right?
Yeah,
they did.
But this one had the different album cover and a couple of different tracks on
it.
The Australian version.
Anyways,
let's continue.
Uh,
the real problem I have with the mistake isn't that,
um,
uh,
I'd be ashamed to call Phil Rudd a Kiwi.
Look.
First of all,
I had to look up Kiwi to figure out what the fuck is a kiwi and to Kiwi,
evidently Kiwis are flightless birds endemic to New Zealand.
I don't know what endemic means.
Is that the uh,
animal version of indigenous or does endemic means some fucking douche bag was
trying to get pussy and brought that bird back to New Zealand?
I have no idea.
Anyways,
Kiwi are flightless birds and Demec to New Zealand.
Um,
had around the sides.
There are about the size of a domestic chicken,
um,
uh,
an organic chicken or one of those Barry bonds roided out ones that Purdue makes
because people love chicken breasts so much.
Did you guys ever see that food inc and they fucking hopped those chicken so
much on,
on steroids that they can't even walk.
They fucking do the ric flair.
Do the flare flop.
Their fucking chest are so goddamn big.
Like,
like,
uh,
like those fucking roided out guys muscle heads from the 80s who didn't do
squats.
That's what they look like.
Oh,
I got on my z cavalry cheese,
right?
And they had the big chest and a little fucking pencil legs and they'd have like
two bears and they fall face first into the sand.
That's what these birds,
that's what the,
uh,
the ones with the horse tranquilizers in their fucking titties look like.
This one actually looks like the size of a,
uh,
of an organic chicken.
Um,
have you guys done that by the way?
If you're going into like an organic food store and see what an apple is
supposed to look like as opposed to the,
the,
uh,
the Sammy Sosa Mark McGuire one,
the Roger Clemens one,
and it's like you get halfway through and you're like full,
you have to put it down.
Hey,
you want to split this apple?
You never said that as a kid,
did you?
Um,
anyways,
there are flightless bird endemic to New Zealand.
And so I was like,
all right,
a kiwi.
Now is that offensive?
Like can like only someone from New Zealand say that they're a kiwi,
but me not being from New Zealand say that you're a kiwi.
Is that offensive?
Um,
so then I looked that up.
it says originates from the Kiwi Bird people live in New Zealand,
the country right next to,
or pretty close to Australia.
Jesus,
could they dumb it down anymore?
Uh,
it's not an offensive term,
but can be offensive if a nasty word is before or after it.
Well,
Jesus Christ doesn't that,
that pretty much sums up every God damn word out there.
You know,
this is my girlfriend.
This is my fucking girlfriend.
All of a sudden have that becomes offensive.
What honey?
I just said you're my girlfriend.
No use.
It's the way you said it.
You will all like,
this is my fucking girlfriend.
And you had this look of of just utter,
just resentment.
No,
you did.
I just told her to stand.
Werewell went wrong.
Everything was going great.
And the second that fucking bitch came,
started working where you work,
all of a sudden you're always working late
lady,
will you just shut up?
Sorry,
I don't even know where the fuck I was going with that.
But yeah,
every basically,
so basically if
they're trying to say a kiwi is usually a good bloke and as a big rivalry to
Australia when it comes to sports,
uh,
you defend a New Zealand Zealander by calling him an Aussie,
but they don't hate each other that much.
I'd hope this is what this person wrote and would stick up for each other if it
came to an arc.
If it came to arguments with America,
for example,
do not shag sheep.
I don't know what that means.
Is that,
is that an offensive term to us?
You calling us sheep?
We sheep.
What?
Cause we uh,
couldn't stop George Bush.
Is that what you're saying?
The fuck's going on?
Everybody is against America right now.
Like they never did any dirty shit.
Go read a history book.
You guys are all fucked.
You know what it is?
America right now is like what the Patriots were like three years ago when we
were in the middle or four or five years ago when in the middle of the dynasty
everybody fucking hated us because we were winning.
Now I don't get it cause we're not even winning.
We're like fucking broken.
You guys still hate us,
you know,
you know at least we got a fucking point of view up here in New Zealand and
Australia.
You know,
you know what,
you guys are like New Zealand and fucking Australia as far as when it comes to
world politics.
You like that like non-offensive comedian who just goes up there with a sweater
and works totally clean.
You know,
never walks.
Anyone in the crowd has not one fucking offensive goddamn opinion.
You know,
hey,
you know,
it's just,
what's the deal with like lamps?
What's up with though?
Why do I always say lamps?
We try to pick something.
Let me try to update that.
Coffee tables.
What's the deal with Labor Day?
Nobody goes to work.
Um,
that's what you guys are like just observational.
It's weird because you go down to Australia and they're fucking angry.
Sons of bitches,
they really are.
Don't head bunch of teeth.
You fucking cunt.
I never heard that until I went to Melbourne,
Australia.
Um,
but whatever,
continue the trashing of America.
I actually know something.
I watched the youtube clip and a,
there was a comedian evidently who was from America and he was on a game show
and uh,
you know,
one of those English game that's kind,
Kinda more clever than funny.
And uh,
there's,
there's other comedians on there.
One of them I guess was English and at some point he,
he fucking trashes America.
The whole crowd goes fucking nuts.
And then the guy looks at the American comedian and just goes like,
you know,
it must be hard for,
everybody just talking about what Shite America is.
And uh,
the fucking dude just sat there and took it and I just wished I could have
fucking walked over like Whoopi Goldberg second time making that reference.
Whoopi Goldberg in Ghost and just fucking,
you know,
I don't know Patrick Swayze,
when he sat down on Whoopi Goldberg and just inhabited a black,
I wish I could've done then at that point and just been like,
wait a fuck does England get off trashing anybody's foreign fucking policy?
You know,
why don't you guys go home collectively as a country and brush your teeth?
Why don't you fucking start with that?
So fucking annoying.
All the,
you know,
it'd be,
if it comes from a fucking country that never did shit,
then I don't have a problem with it.
And I get it and I even still get it,
but it's just,
you know,
it's one of those things,
it's like,
only I can kick the shit out of my little brother.
You can't,
I guess it's like that Kiwi thing,
you know?
So whenever that comic was,
who said that stuff going for the cheap fucking laugh.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
you fucking hack.
I hope the rest of your teeth fall out and you spend the rest of your career
working at Goddamn game show.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
so there's that happy part of the podcast.
Uh,
we've learned some things this week,
haven't we?
Grover Cleveland is the only president.
Do what?
Serve two terms.
Nonconsecutive Lee,
he's the 22nd and 24th President Labor Day started in what city?
Everybody.
New York City.
And it became a national holiday when,
what?
When the United States military shut up some fucking guys who wanted to get a
eight bucks an hour over at ups,
unloading trucks
and Kiwi Kiwi's of flightless bird.
That is a
egg nematic and ego maniac of fucking Louisiana with I,
you know,
whatever.
Two out of three,
two out of fucking three.
There we go.
Um,
so right now actually,
you know what,
you know,
my screensaver is if I can just let you guys way too far into my life.
And it used to be,
there's this picture of Paul Newman and uh,
Jackie Gleason from the movie,
the Hustler and a now I actually,
I got a 65 Oldsmobile cutlass convertible white,
black top black interior with the factory fucking hubcaps.
Looks like a little old lady drove it.
And um,
I would put some rims on it.
But like that's the kind of thing that I'm thinking about getting out here.
Now after my experience with just having a v six dodge challenger in la trying
to drive it.
Oh,
pull,
pull.
That's it.
You know,
why does anybody out there,
somebody from Oregon told me that they actually bought the dodge challenger with
the stick shift in the Hemi,
the one that I want.
And they actually,
can you please send me video of what I,
the dream I could be living if I was up in Portland,
Oregon.
Um,
I would just,
and I can,
I live vicariously through that.
Cause other than that I actually get,
why am I,
I really think back to all those gangster rap videos and all those low rider
videos,
the Latinos and black dudes out here.
MMM.
There was a lot of Chevelles.
Yes.
A lot of impalas.
You know,
a lot of those kinds of just cruising around kind of cars and,
and you know what?
Now that I live out here,
I get it.
I totally fucking get it.
Having a muscle car out here,
it's fucking stupid.
So frustrating.
But uh,
it's not going to prevent me from getting a,
uh,
from getting an old car.
I gotta do it,
man.
I fucking love those things.
All right,
close tabs.
Let's move on to the next thing.
Let's get onto the,
uh,
youtube videos for the week,
everybody.
MMM.
Okay.
Let's see here.
Youtube actually had the urge to fucking crack open of labor day beer.
Why don't I do that and fucking drink with you guys.
I'm going to hit pause right here and we're going to ride it out.
Ride it out here.
Hang on.
Wait,
hang on.
One second.
Hitting pause.
All right,
and I'm back.
Magic of hitting pause on back drinking a bud light.
It's a pussy beer.
How do you know how the bud light's ended up in there?
Nia had some people over and came home,
you know,
the usual,
some brought 12 pack over and no one was drinking.
So I had this mechanic killing these all week and I got to MIT for a light beer.
It's very tasty.
I a underrated bud light.
I think it's very underrated.
Lot of light beers.
I'm not,
I'm not a fan of,
you know,
I don't do that shit.
You know,
if I'm going to get ice cream,
I don't get low fat ice cream.
I don't get yogurt.
I fuck,
I'm getting ice cream.
You know,
I'll get on the treadmill.
I don't give a fuck.
Hey,
speaking of which,
how's a,
how you doing out there?
Uh,
what did they say?
A fucking pasty hips sachet and across the White House.
You still on your fucking treadmill.
You've got to do it up.
Don't quit.
Don't fucking quit.
Um,
you know,
what's funny man,
I really realized like a,
you guys suffer from depression or at least negative thought the way I do.
Um,
I've really found out that my diet and working out can really keep me out of
those funks like,
um,
this whole week when I was shooting the pilot,
you know,
rather than letting you know,
thoughts of doubt creep in.
Like I've really figured out how my brain works.
Like when it,
when you know,
like just the way I'm wired because of my childhood,
I will walk up to a set and rather than be like,
wow,
this is what you worked,
you're on the
set of a,
of a TV show that actually,
you know,
you're going to be one of the stars of isn't this great.
My first thought,
the first thing my brain says is,
what if you fuck up and they fire you and everybody finds out about it and
everybody laughs at you and then you never get work again and you have to move
back in with your parents.
That's the first thought that my brain says.
So I am conscious of it.
I let it happen and I just think like really,
Bill,
do you want to spoon with that fucking thought in your head as you go in and try
and do these scenes or do you want to think something else?
Send A,
one of the big things that has helped me asides from being aware of negative
thought and just making the choice to not fucking,
you know,
jump on that slide down to depression is how I eat and I go over to the craft
service and I got a bowl of oatmeal with raisins to total healthy breakfast.
Totally skipped a big fucking breakfast burritos and all that.
I'm telling you,
man,
you have an order set shit.
When you're in a depressed depression,
all of a sudden you're at Mcdonald's and you just go eat a double fucking
cheeseburger and it sends you a salt through the roof.
You're like,
hi,
like yeah,
this is great.
And then then you just crash and then you feel even fucking worse.
I'm telling you,
go to what God damn juice store,
drink a juice and go on a hike or go get on a fucking treadmill.
And just actually eat a healthy meal and it'll,
I'm telling you,
at least it works for me.
I don't think we've ever,
we've never really talk about depression,
you know,
that curl up in a ball.
I didn't want to move,
um,
type of shit,
so I don't even know I got on that Goddamn topic.
But,
um,
anyways,
I've lived a very happy life for the last three,
four years.
You wouldn't know it,
listened to the podcast,
but I obviously ramp up shit.
But,
um,
just by figuring out how my brain works and then making the decision to not,
I dunno,
just not hang out with negative thought and not hang around people either.
Who think like that,
you know,
sell.
There you go.
There's my little,
for now I'm feeling like a fucking fucking fag.
We'll be here like I'm giving you actually good advice here.
I usually give you more ronic advice.
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the,
uh,
soil underrated,
overweight rated for the week.
I actually didn't have time because I was shooting that thing,
so I'll give you a couple.
A underrated,
a bud lite beer.
Uh,
underrated,
uh,
getting to do was show tape a pilot for comedy central with one of your great
friends in the business.
It,
uh,
overrated driving a muscle car in Los Angeles.
There you go.
That's the underrated overrated for the week.
And uh,
here's some youtube videos for the week.
Um,
and here also,
by the way,
you guys and I really stress somebody out there,
one of my listeners,
please try and come up with an idea where you can make a fuck load of money here
because this guy is making a zillion dollars with this youtube video.
Um,
it's called the I renew bracelet.
It's,
I like Ipod,
renew all one word,
no dash capital I renew bracelet.
All these are on the [inaudible] podcast.com by the way.
So you can just watch all these if you don't want to write these things down.
I the I renew bracelet,
uh,
and it's and get more energy with IRA knew.
And it's basically you just have to watch what this product is in the
unbelievable bullshit video that they put with it and just know that somebody is
a fucking millionaire because of this idea.
All right,
you guys want to get out of your cubicles?
why don't we take the podcast in the next level rather than me making you laugh
in your fucking cubicle when I try and help you get out of it.
I'm telling you,
just come up with some stupid bullshit idea.
For 1995 I saw one today,
I was actually walking down the street and I saw this old,
a Ford Ranger two wheel drive pickup.
That was my first car.
So I was like,
Oh wow,
look at that.
And it had the cleats on the side.
And the thing is when you have cleats on the side of your,
your your pickup bed,
the worst thing about them is like when you walk by,
they snag your clothes or even the worst,
they scrape your fucking skin off.
Well,
somebody came up with retractable ones.
You know,
I must have scraped my fucking arm a zillion time on the cleats I had on the
side of my truck.
And it never dawned on me how to fix that,
you know,
I mean,
maybe that'll help you out.
I have no idea.
I'd wish we'd love to see one of you guys become a fucking millionaire and,
uh,
you know,
and get out of the Goddamn cubicle life.
Um,
next,
next one.
Um,
and this actually goes along the lines of the kid learning how to play drums
and,
or just learning how to play an instrument or just in general.
If you like music,
look up the dead weather to Jack White Blend Brant,
Jack White Band.
Fuck.
Can't talk this week.
Check white band.
Uh,
look up the dead weather Letterman,
their performance on Letterman.
It's just,
it's,
it's everything that fucking music should be because the second I saw it,
I got the fucking chills and I was like,
I want to be Jack White.
And that's when you know you're watching a real rock star.
You get the chills and you want to be that fucking guy.
And after you watch it,
you watch it again and then you watch it again and then you download it and then
you put it on your iPod and then you go on a fucking hike and you're listening
to it and you're fantasizing that you were actually Jack White.
And that I actually took the fantasy to that level,
like I killed doing standup and then let them and said,
great job.
Hey,
I heard you also have a band.
And then I went out.
Oh yeah,
I just mess around.
You know,
like that's the level,
that's how good that fucking song is that I took the delusional fantasy to that
level.
Do you guys ever have any of those,
those delusional fantasies when you see something so cool that you then walk
around talking to yourself,
inserting yourself into that situation?
Or Am I just completely out of my mind?
Huh?
All right.
Let me take another Swig of my Labor Day beer here.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
this is,
this is a great youtube video here.
Uh,
it's funny.
Fake floorboard hotwater prank.
And I know a lot of you guys are aware of these,
but I gotta tell you something.
When it comes to prank shows,
the Jimi Hendrix of prank shows,
uh,
the Japanese people,
um,
I don't know if it's Chinese too.
I have no,
I fucking idea,
but I think it's pretty much Japan.
These dudes take practical jokes to a level where you just like the,
even the person who sent me the email,
it's like,
obviously there's no lawyers,
there's no lawsuits.
The shit that you can do to people.
Funny fake floorboard hotwater prank,
just not to totally give it away.
It's a fake floorboard.
Not only does the person fall through the floorboard,
not only did they go into water with their street clothes on,
it's hot water,
and then there's like this pile of ice that you then have to get out and jump
onto
and you look at these people's face that the prank happens to the,
they're like tortured animals.
It's brutal,
but it's fucking hilarious.
So check that out if you guys can find some more of those.
I know there was a classic one where they had one with this guy was walking
around and he would pretend to sneeze.
He walked up right behind a complete stranger,
be like chew and he would,
he had a water bottle room temperature water and he would spray it on the back
of the guy's neck and just see what the person would do like they're out of
their fucking minds.
Anyways,
last youtube video the week.
Um,
oh,
a gangsta with an a with gun gets beaten by skaters and um,
I love,
I,
you know,
I don't like watching those,
those,
you know,
I like watching a fight as much as anybody,
but I don't really don't like watching somebody just completely get pounded to
the ground is something that's just,
that's a little too animalistic after a while,
if there's not a ref there to kind of stop it,
I can't get into it.
But,
um,
I do like the videos if you guys can find videos.
I love the fight,
the street fight videos where somebody talking shit and then they get knocked
out like that pimp who talks shit to the martial artists.
This is one,
this is like some gang banger takes out a gun.
I don't know what happened,
but somehow he gets beaten down by like three other skateboarders.
Um,
and please don't read the comments because it all just becomes this racist,
depressing horseshit.
But,
um,
if you just watched the video,
it's actually funny in an,
actually,
if you look closely when you watch the video,
it presents a question I've had for a long time is why when you get not just
beat down,
when you get beat down,
beat down.
This is the question I've had.
Why do you always lose a shoe?
You know,
it's fucking unbelievable.
And it's like one of the deals when the smoke clears,
the dude always has,
one shoe was on and one shoe is off.
And you would think that you would see the shoe fly off,
but you never do.
I'm sure if you go back and you watch the video and you just look at the
person's feet,
you're going to see when it comes off.
But this dude in the end of it is missing a shoe.
You always see that one white gym shock the guy's hairs all over the place.
Your fucking ears are hot and you're just always missing a fucking shoe.
Do I have any scientists who listened to this thing?
Could explain if you guys have any theory as to why you lose a fucking shoe,
I am all ears.
I'm all right with that.
I'm going to start to wrap up this podcast and like I said,
uh,
we got the 99 cent ring tone on the,
the mm podcast,
the Oh gee,
use fucking ringtone.
Um,
please check it out and please donate.
And um,
you know,
if I can somehow get 700 fucking people to do it,
I'm going to go out and go buy that recorder and start driving around doing
these things again at some point.
Um,
and with that we will end with this thing here for the podcast.
A bill.
This is under women in diamonds.
Um,
so bill,
I'm at a party last night and I see a guy I haven't seen in a long time.
He's got his girl with them.
She's pretty hot,
but she's got this Puss,
a look on her face.
Uh,
we,
we were introduced earlier,
so I say,
so I say hey to her and uh,
and ask her what's wrong?
Turns out she's had a few,
a few drinks and is throwing around the,
I want to get married.
Shit.
Um,
I don't think my buddies having any of it or at the very least plans to go down
swinging.
Um,
so anyways,
nothing like a party to bring that shit up anyway.
So I figured this is the perfect opportunity to test out a new theory I have
about diamonds.
I'm not really a theory,
but a great question that allows women to show their true colors.
Why do I do this?
Because I'm a smart ass jerk when I have a few whiskeys.
I liked this guy.
This guy sounds like me.
Right?
Why would you actually try to get the girl on your side and well actually you
wouldn't hook up at your buddy's girl,
but you know what I mean?
Why would you put out a good vibe when you can actually piss people off?
I totally relate to that.
Um,
anyways,
second half here.
Anyway,
from what I understand,
you can basically,
now,
I don't know if this is true or not,
but this guy's claiming from what I understand,
you can basically buy a real diamond created in a lab.
Um,
eventually they will be much cheaper than the ones they have to dig out of the
ground and they will also be flawless.
A fucking perfect diamond.
So I asked this girl,
I say if she,
if she would rather have a perfect,
flawless diamond created in a lab that costs a lot less or insist on a real dug
out of the ground diamond by some poor person in Africa,
nearly perfect,
but ultimately flawed more than
it's an expensive one.
Um,
he,
he said you can pretty much guess her answer.
Once again,
women are fucking stupid about diamonds.
Uh,
all right.
My first question is,
can they really create one in a lab that's much cheaper and if they,
if they can for the love of God,
shut the fuck up about it.
That should be some low like Guy Shit,
you know,
and,
and this is what,
this is what we would do like you,
this is that this is the level that you organize it too.
All right?
Just so they don't catch on,
you know,
because some guy who fucking stock shelves at seven 11 is able to buy the hope
fucking diamond,
the broads,
we'll be able to figure it out quickly.
So we should do is organize his shit like the beginning of the warriors,
except nobody shoots Cyrus.
Okay,
we organize this shit and this is what we say.
You come in with your w two for the fucking year.
All right?
We see what you make.
And then we give you an unbelievable fucking diamond from making that amount of
money.
Whatever we rather than,
what's it supposed to cost?
Six weeks' pay.
We give you one that costs like 10 weeks,
you know,
put some fake beads of sweat on your fucking brow when you give it to her and
the whole thing's going to look legit and me while we take that money to go buy
a new flat screen.
All right.
And that's when you make the fucking move or after you give it the diamond.
Okay.
Say I bought that diamond for you.
Now I want to buy something for me.
Actually,
why don't you help me out on this?
Just throw me a hundred,
200 bucks in this thing.
You go out and get a big fucking flat screen TV.
You get the fucking dish just in time for NFL football.
You know,
and I'm sure they offer a college football fucking package and then you just
spend the rest of the football season Saturday and Sunday and total fucking
bliss.
And anytime she gives you shit,
just be like,
I'm sorry honey,
I couldn't hear you over the glare of the fucking diamond I put on your goddamn
finger.
That's what.
Well that's what should have happened.
If I had half a brain,
I wouldn't have read that part over the Goddamn a podcast.
But,
um,
I actually get that on some level.
Why she would want the other one.
I don't get it because I don't want to think about some poor kid digging that
out of the ground.
That's the part where it goes off the rails.
But they want,
you know,
they want something of value,
and they,
they,
I dunno if they want to show that they married a provider.
I get it on some level.
They want to make their friends jealous.
Like,
um,
I think their obsession with diamonds,
you know,
generally speaking is as dumb is our obsession with sports because when you
really think about it,
our obsession with sports is really fucking stupid.
You know,
sitting on your couch like a God damn cheerleader wearing the Jersey of your
favorite player.
I mean,
not everybody does that,
but there,
you know,
fantasy football,
I mean,
fantasy football to me is the male version of sex in the city of women watching
sex in the city.
For you to sit around and play fantasy football and get together with your
friends and have a fucking draft.
I mean,
you might as well do it in a Goddamn tree fort.
It's really one of the gayest fucking things you could possibly do.
And of course I am saying this,
having never tried it and I know God damn well fight tried it.
I'd be like,
this is fucking awesome.
You know,
past the dip or whatever you fucking guys do.
Um,
but anyways,
I dunno,
I just,
I,
you know,
it's book.
If I've learned anything in life,
women are crazy and guys are fucking idiots and uh,
it's not straight across the board,
but generally speaking,
yeah,
they're fucking nuts.
They're out of their minds and we're morons.
I mean,
when you,
if you go on youtube and you just look up those fail videos,
most of them are guys trying to do something and they fucking get hit in the
balls,
land on the back of their head,
wreck their car.
How many women are driving down the street on a fucking motorcycle going 90
miles an hour,
trying to stand up on the seat.
Doing the karate kid pose is they point at the fucking camera and then fucking
skin,
get skin their fucking asses.
I mean,
how many,
you know what I mean?
How many,
how many fucking women are,
are,
are fucking whatever that move that Asian dude does or whatever,
where he fucking somehow gets his car to be doing donuts and he actually gets
out of the car and is holding onto the steering wheel and it's still spinning
around.
Somehow he's got the gas pedal
pushed all the way down.
Basically in the end he gets run over by his own fucking car.
I mean,
we're idiots.
All right.
Women on the other hand go to movies and start crying like they actually know
the fucking people on screen get all excited about shiny shit.
And uh,
I gotta be honest,
I don't even know what the fuck they get excited about.
I have such a difficult time listening to them
out of such a great chauvinist Dick thing to say as I fucking took a slug of
beer here.
Um Wow.
You know I'm going to get shit faced.
That's what I'm doing.
I gotta,
I gotta upload this thing.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm going out on my little balcony.
I don't have a porch and I'm gonna sit there in the fucking breeze and I'm going
to get hammered with my girl because um,
cause that's cause it's America,
you know?
I'm sure in England you're doing something smart,
right?
What are you guys doing over there?
Huh?
Eat some Indian food.
Why are you guys teeth the color of curry?
Okay.
Why am I shitting on England?
It was one fucking comedian for all.
I know that guy was from Ireland.
I'm just breaking balls.
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm really whatever.
I'm like you guys.
I'm fucking defensive of my own goddamn country.
I know we're,
we're really in a bad place right now as a country,
but I say it not you.
I say it.
You got death.
All right.
Happy Labor Day.
Happy a fucking trails.
And,
uh,
come on,
man.
99 cents,
99 fucking sense.
Look into your heart and a downloaded,
it'd be fucking riot.
You'll be at work and your phone and be going,
oh gee.
It's going to be great.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys have a great week.
I'm going to be at the comedy works in Denver,
Colorado this Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Next week I'm going to be at xannies comedy club,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Um,
all the dates are up on a bill bird.com.
And uh,
we'll have the link there and the [inaudible] podcast and [inaudible] dot com
and all that stuff.
All right guys,
I'll talk to you next week.